y
[Música]
las tropas rusas volvieron a bombardear
jarquín primera vez desde que aquéllas
fueron expulsadas de la segunda ciudad
más grande de ucrania
moscú concentró a sus ataques en el
donbass mientras que incluso la moneda
rusa será una de las dos oficiales
ya está en china la alta comisionada de
la onu para los derechos humanos con su
visita de seis días michelle bachelet
investigará las denuncias de presuntos
abusos contra la etnia musulmana de los
uigur es un señalamiento de occidente
que beijing rechaza
el presidente chileno gabriel boric
promulgó la ley que da el mayor aumento
del salario mínimo en 25 años este
incremento será en dos fases hasta
llegar a 480 dólares un monto que es de
los más bajos de la ocde tendremos
reporte desde santiago
bienvenidos a las noticias en france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes iniciamos con
lo más reciente de la guerra en ucrania
por primera vez desde que las tropas
rusas fueron expulsadas de la región de
jarquín la segunda ciudad más importante
del país fue bombardeada el centro de
esta urbe fue atacado con un
lanzacohetes que dispara municiones en
racimo según denunciaron los militares
ucranianos esta arma está prohibida por
los tratados internacionales de una
persona resultó herida por otra parte
del presidente de volodymyr selenski
afirmó que los rusos estaban perpetrando
un baño de sangre en la región del
donbass donde se concentra su operación
militar las ciudades más golpeadas allí
son slogans y severodonezk y ejercen una
de las urbes más grandes controladas
ahora por moscú introdujeron el rublo
como moneda oficial así la moneda rusa
tendrá el mismo peso que la crisma
ucraniana
y con una sentencia a cadena perpetua
terminó el primer juicio por crímenes de
guerra en ucrania una corte de ese país
condenó al sargento ruso vadim sisi
marín quien tiene 21 años el mismo ya se
había declarado culpable por el
homicidio de un civil de 62 años
ocurrido al inicio de la guerra
ampliamos en el informe
podría sentar un precedente legal el
lunes un juez de una corte de kiev
sentenció a cadena perpetua a un soldado
ruso acusado de cometer crímenes de
guerra a finales de febrero badín chis y
marín de 21 años disparó contra un
hombre que iba en bicicleta en la
localidad de sapac ipca en el noreste de
ucrania
nacido el 17 de octubre del 2000 es
declarado culpable de haber cometido
ofensa criminal de acuerdo el artículo
438 del código penal ucraniano queda
condenado a cadena perpetua el soldado
no mostró ningún tipo de emoción al
escuchar el veredicto su abogado había
intentado buscar una absolución
argumentando que su cliente tan solo
ejecutó una orden directa que
anteriormente había desobedecido hace
unos días aseguró a la corte que no
tenía intenciones de matar
[Música]
me arrepiento sinceramente estaba
nervioso porque en el momento en el que
ocurrió había enfrentamientos yo no
quería matar a la víctima pero así es
como ocurrió y no lo niego
su caso no será el último ucrania acusa
a rusia de atrocidades generalizadas y
brutalidad contra la población civil las
autoridades han identificado más de
10.000 posibles crímenes de guerra
cometidos por rusia el kremlin niega que
sus tropas hayan matado a civiles
por primera vez en la historia en todo
el mundo hay más de 100 millones de
desplazados y refugiados según el más
reciente reporte de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados acnur de ellos 14
millones de personas han huido por la
guerra en ucrania y es que la invasión
rusa y los múltiples golpes de estado
que ha habido en áfrica aceleraron el
desplazamiento además hay otros
conflictos que llevan décadas y que han
obligado a miles de personas a dejar sus
hogares arianna villacorta tiene los
detalles
más de 100 millones de refugiados y
desplazados en el mundo es decir el 1
por ciento de la población mundial el
aumento acelerado se produjo
principalmente a causa de la guerra en
ucrania en la medida que más de 14
millones de ucranianos
principalmente mujeres y niños se han
visto obligados a desplazarse 8 millones
lo han hecho dentro de ucrania mientras
que 6 millones han cruzado las fronteras
sin embargo no se pueden dejar de lado
otros conflictos como explicó a france
24 william spindler portavoz en américa
latina' de la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados tenemos situaciones que
llevan años décadas e incluso en donde
generaciones de refugiados continúan sin
poder volver a sus países y es por eso
que no solamente es la respuesta
humanitaria que es esencial para salvar
vidas pero también una voluntad política
de encontrar una solución de acabar con
los conflictos de promover el diálogo
de evitar que hayan estas persecuciones
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
son esenciales si queremos realmente
resolver esta situación
spindler también advirtió que la
situación en latinoamérica es igual de
alarmante que la que se vive en etiopía
burkina faso mianmar nigeria afganistán
y la república democrática del congo
también en nuestra región vemos esta
situación de desarraigo
del desplazamiento del éxodo de millones
de personas que tienen que dejar sus
hogares ya sea para desplazarse dentro
de sus países o hacia otros países la
situación en nuestra región es también
muy preocupante el 20 de mayo la acnur
pidió a varios países levantar las
restricciones contra el kobe 19 en las
que muchos se han aferrado para negar
asilo a las personas que huyen de los
conflictos este organismo señala que
contravienen un derecho fundamental
ya llegó a china la alta comisionada de
la onu para los derechos humanos
michelle bachelet en su visita de seis
días investigar a los presuntos abusos
contra la minoría de los uigures en la
provincia de xinjiang sin embargo cerca
de 200 organizaciones dicen que están
preocupadas por la falta de libertad con
la que la funcionaria de las naciones
unidas- podría realizar sus labores en
territorio chino esta es la primera vez
desde 2005 que el líder de dicha oficina
de la onu va a china
parte de la comunidad internacional
lleva tiempo expresando su escepticismo
sobre la credibilidad de la misión de la
jefa de la onu michelle bachelet en
china las palabras de beijing de este
lunes no lograron tranquilizar a los
críticos
debido al impacto de la epidemia la
visita de bachelet a china tendrá un
enfoque cerrado las dos partes han
acordado no organizar visitas de
seguimiento de periodistas con
transmisión ya fue la presión para que
la onu de luz verde sobre la situación
en xinjiang ha ido en aumento una parada
clave en la visita de bachelet las
autoridades chinas han sido acusadas de
cometer abusos de derechos humanos
contra los uigures de la región algo que
el gobierno chino niega y ahora que
vigilan de ser que el viaje de bachelet
algunos temen que la jefa de la onu no
pueda acceder libremente para constatar
las condiciones en xinjiang
al tratar algunos temas muy importantes
y delicados espero que esto nos ayude a
crear confianza y nos permita trabajar
juntos para avanzar en la promoción y
cooperación en materia de derechos
humanos en china pero también a nivel
mundial
o
la onu señala que hasta un millón de
personas están retenidas en campos de
jinxiang debido a su fe musulmana
eeuu dice que china está cometiendo un
genocidio contra los figures pero el
gobierno lo rechaza argumentando que las
instalaciones se utilizan para combatir
el extremismo
washington también ha criticado a
bachelet afirmando que la jefa de la onu
no ha defendido a la comunidad uigur
en noticias de américa latina en chile
entra en vigor el mayor aumento del
salario mínimo que ha habido en casi 30
años este lunes el presidente de gabriel
boric promulgó la ley que la semana
pasada aprobó el parlamento chileno la
norma incrementa el ingreso básico en un
14,3 por ciento
esta subida se logró después de un
histórico acuerdo entre el ejecutivo y
la central unitaria de trabajadores que
es el sindicato más grande del país
vamos a santiago la capital chilena
donde nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
nos amplía la información
el presidente chileno gabriel boric
promulgó este lunes la ley que
incrementa el salario mínimo de los
chilenos el mayor aumento nominal en los
últimos 29 años según afirmó el
mandatario que beneficiará a un total de
850 mil trabajadores así a partir de
este lunes el sueldo mínimo pasa de 410
a 445 dólares y de 445 a
468 en agosto un aumento de 58 dólares
acumulados en un solo año la medida
incluye también una serie de subsidios
para 180.000 pequeñas y medianas
empresas de 26 dólares a partir de mayo
y 30 a partir de agosto para que esto
redunde en un mejor salario de sus
trabajadores nuestro gobierno está
profundamente comprometido con un
trabajo decente que garantice a los
trabajadores y trabajadoras de nuestro
país el acceso a un ingreso justo
manifestó el presidente al promulgar
esta ley que va muy en la línea con lo
comprometido por su gobierno que asegura
que de aquí al final de su mandato en
2026 el sueldo mínimo alcanzará un total
de 585 dólares esto chile como en muchos
otros lugares del mundo se vive una ola
inflacionaria el año pasado la inflación
registró un 10 5 por ciento en su tasa
la más alta en los últimos 28 años sigan
con más información en france 24
[Música]